difficult being so beautiful babes oh no
no no it's okay this isn't this takes a
lot of help walkabouts Carlene Josh
Smith and today we're joined by the new
pop sensation even max how are you I'm
gonna pose some agony art style
questions to you let's do it and you're
gonna help solve some serious life
issues are you ready to get your agony
on on yes I need to up my game and get
me a man on a Saturday night on the
dance floor oh this guy's got struggles
what is the aver max go-to move what
does because you're the queen of a dance
routine like I've seen those down below
yeah it doesn't have to be all the way
to the ground but some sort of jump in
low and then make it like pop kind of
like Legally Blonde I wash up I love
that I can pop up over top and top drop
into top pop thunders knock that is come
up the 360 experiences wow so you're
picking up yeah and then you go BAM yeah
and you have to have that hair flip you
so even if it's a ever so slightly mm
yeah the half life is very can the hair
flip does do the trick yeah we got
sister Eli you don't know a little wing
oh my god I can't wait I mean that was
very seductive I am seduced I've started
dating a boy oh this is a relative I'm
so ready for this one he's a bit sweet
for the bit psycho Oh inspired problem
here how do I work him out Stark him
well you go full-on stalker
yeah full-on stalker just go see where
he hangs out this friends hide in the
bushes like become the trees like stop
camouflage if you really want to know
you got to go find it so you need to get
your wall paint on get those leaves
Allah oh you know you gotta go if you
like this guy and you feel like he's
being Shady
mm-hmm I would be just a shading the
real Slim Shady is about how I have to
say i if I was confused
I probably to be honest I wouldn't even
bother I would be like I max thank you
max Ariana there we go now you are a
queen of style I mean hello bringing it
today but I'm doing the walk of shame oh
how do I style it out don't give me some
ingredients what do we have we have last
night's makeup on my face we have a
slight mascara situation going on
underneath okay I would add more water
to that
oh I would make it seem like it's
intentional yeah okay make putting more
like literally just like just like smear
it more on just like become the
character and then it looks like you're
faking it which really it's an in
reality you're actually I'm really I
love a little bit karaoke but I'm
useless at taking on another identity Oh
who should i impersonate and what your
top tips I would say like to hit me baby
one more time yes a Britney Britney
Spears baby or hum got Madonna
I mean TLC no scrubs oh I wanted to say
that first but that's really I just I
live die for that song how would you
know your best birthday you gotta give
it some attitude mm-hmm you gotta look
at the camera because you know you're
being filmed what do you sing karaoke
for sure
you got to really feel it close your
eyes and go for it that's your best
friend
I've been zombies ah you know what
zombie means no no
I had to ask okay dictionary definition
is when someone let you were chatting to
someone and they ghost you when you
don't hear from them and then all the
sudden they come back and like hey how
you been oh that's happen yeah we hate
those boys how should I respond do you
shut him down or do you tie with him we
should ignore him
we should ignore them because why why
followed the basal planet and then come
when he they only want something right
Jonna no he's toying with you so you
know drop that black you know it says
black on some every number you can block
anybody I would block him welcome yeah
bye I talked thank you bye bye
boy bye now this is a bit more of like
serious one I'm struggling with
understanding Who I am
what p.m. a tips can you give me I want
to know what you think of it well I
think you should take a good look in the
mirror need to tell you something you're
worth it and then you need you the hair
player and then you need to do the best
then you need to dependence that for
yourself yeah my motto is be yourself
that's it yeah always always and Annie
cause even if anyone if this person
doesn't like you that you're with in a
relationship especially believe them
this person has to love all of you face
thank you so much for empowering us all
with this advice thank you I hope you
learned something
oh wait they're hiding in trees um
following your gut but more empowering
an amazing life advice such as this make
sure you subscribe to the glamour UK
channel
[Music]